[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
incredible Ethan suplee who you may know
from things like My Name is Earl
American History X Kevin Smith movies I
personally know him from life but I'm
also most most admiring most admiring of
his uh his life transformation his body
transformation Ethan was a very very
very big person and he lost 300 pounds
but not only that he's gotten an
incredible shape a journey that he has
chronicled on his own podcast American
Glutton which is an incredible podcast I
think I happen to be the most current
guest as well so you can listen to me
and Ethan chatting there as well we get
into all sorts of wonderful things his
life his life philosophy he's a very
very deeply interesting guy and a very
talented guy and a lovely friend so I'm
excited for you guys to hear this
episode thank you for tuning tuning in
you didn't really tune in did you just
you clicked something if you want to see
me do stand up go to petehomes.com I am
going to be in Houston Texas this
weekend and a lot more tour dates all on
petehomes.com and once a month I am in
Los Angeles doing my show my residency
at Largo go to largo-la.com if you're
going to be in Los Angeles and want to
see me do stand up May the 4th Star Wars
day is the next living at Largo so hope
to see you there or hope to see you on
the road in your hometown and if you
like this show as always why not try a
Pete's pick just one Pete's pick up top
which is here I'm showing it to the
video people this is my Apollo neuro as
you guys know I'm crazy about my Apollo
neuro I'm always talking about it it is
a wearable piece of tech I wear it on
the inside of my wrist that delivers
vibrations that speak to your nervous
system in a language that it can
understand basically simulating the
feeling and The Sensation of like a
wearable hug that you it's basically
touch therapy to help you feel safe and
in control you can wear it on your wrist
or your ankle and though those gentle
soothing vibrations train your nervous
system over time and really the first
time you use it you start feeling it to
recover and rebalance after stress
there's different settings for energy
feeling social feeling clear calm
focused rebuild and Recovery wonderful
recovery after stress or physical
recovery calm which is a great setting
for meditation relax which is what I put
it on at night when I'm trying to unwind
and turn my brain off and my favorite
setting fall asleep which gently lulls
you to sleep and allows you back to
sleep if you're like me and sometimes
wake up in the middle of the night it's
a wonderful chemical free way to get
better sleep better rest better
relaxation and also it's a caffeine
freeway of getting more energy more
focus and more Drive which is awesome it
trains your nervous system to cope with
stress better over time the more you use
it the better it works and it's not
woo-woo I always say this it was
developed by a neuroscientist and a
board-certified psychiatrist who have
been studying the impacts of chronic
stress in humans for nearly 15 years and
apologize effects on stress sleep
cognitive performance and Recovery have
been proven in multiple clinical trials
and real world studies it's absolutely
changed mine and Val's life we've given
it away to dozens of people absolutely a
big life-changing and a life hack a life
hack and helping us cope with stress so
show your support for the show show your
support for your body and your nervous
system you can get 10 off at
apollonuro.com that's Apollo
n-e-u-r-o.com slash weird and get a
wearable hug on your wrist or your ankle
and help you cope and deal with the
stress that life throws at you with
wearable technology alright everybody
that's it up top enjoy my chat with my
friend Ethan suplee get into it oops
oops
what's going on dude are you home by the
way I've been home for one day and I got
a sunburn
well we've been in Toronto
it's sunny here you're in Florida yeah
Florida
five minutes in Florida and I've got a
sunburn because Toronto bleached me of
melanin I guess yeah well also gave me
depression I don't know if it gave me
depression but like since being home
the first thing I did today I thought of
you I did a little coldie I did a little
icy yes and uh I was like God I gotta
watch it like I'm always telling people
to do it maybe some people just don't
want to do it it's like when we talked
about it you remember you said I'm
sweating I got it's by the way even you
just saying this right now there's such
a fear it's so crazy yeah and you know
because I haven't done it I haven't been
home in a week and I hadn't done it in a
week and just a week away from it made
it like a new like fresh and painful
Anew so I got in it and I was like this
is what you're telling people to do like
I wasn't like right you weren't right
like a month from now you're gonna just
be like no it's wonderful back to that
yeah but it was good it was I'm sure
you're maybe you can relate when you
haven't worked out or whatever in a
while and you go oh this is really hard
I don't think you really do that anymore
but like back when you did I'm at that
place with that I'm like I got in and
immediately thought of you but
I was in the Sun that was part of it I
was like it was um old huberman Andrew
huberman was like the first thing you
should do for your metabolism for your
mood and everything is in the eyes yeah
not in the eyes no sunglasses get into
the eyes yeah I I'm fortunate that this
is an overshare but my bathroom I can
open the window so the sun is coming in
so like everybody's doing there like I
do a journaling thing in the morning on
my phone and so I just take a long sit
pee
sure
that maybe turns into a dumper room we
don't know we don't know like it's the
luxury that ladies enjoy because ladies
are always sitting they get they're like
oh I didn't know I had to take it yeah
it's just happening it's it's a bonus
that's what [__] happens means actually
we thought it meant bad things happen
but it's actually ladies seating it's
nice you feel better but I get that sun
and when we were in Canada I was like
it's not a foregone conclusion that you
live in a place where that exists that's
where like seasonal affective lights and
all that sort of stuff has to come into
play because I was hurting for it yeah
real bad and I mean correct me if I'm
wrong but I I you know we were staying
in a downtown area but even like New
York is sunnier than Toronto at least
the time of year yeah I kept saying that
and they were like well in the summer
it's sunny and I was like oh right of
course I guess and towards the end of
our filming it started to get sunny but
I I'm a little bit that way I'll ever if
I go to turn on a six times and it's
overcast the whole time I'll just go
ahead and assume it's overcast the whole
year yeah it's
foreign
because where it wasn't like cloudy it
wasn't sunny it's so it's so foreign to
my experiences the sun just skips it the
sun just doesn't go over Canada yeah but
what that does to you and I actually
wrote it down I've never talked to you
and we're recording that's okay right
here okay yeah I mean we're we're
getting weird
I already talked about how women I think
take more dumps because every time they
they sit down right and and I think that
they're hopeful also there's a
hopefulness yeah you know yeah it's
gonna happen it could happen they're
just more in the flow and I think it's
just because they're sitting down to pee
we thought it was estrogen we thought it
was conditioning or culture or
childbirth or whatever it is it's
because they're sitting down to pee yeah
you know I have four daughters and a
wife and now a granddaughter so I'm
surrounded by women and it was uh
decades ago that I began regularly
sitting down I understand the morning I
understand you're tired you're half
asleep but there was something about
like just the just the act of
re-lowering the toilet seat for me I was
like I'm gonna cut out the middleman I'm
just gonna sit and I've had like Super
Macho friends who uh yes yes desire this
to be a a state of masculation right
you're sitting to pee how dare you even
simply first of all I'm gonna cut you to
the end me too I'm already there I'm
already there but I'm preferring of
course why stand when you can sit which
I believe Queen Elizabeth said about
baths I'm saying about urination it's
the best and also it's sort of nasty
it's just sort of nasty like draining a
hose getting it everywhere splashing
yeah I'm too old for this [__] I'm too
old for this piss yeah
I I don't even know that my wife knows
this and and she would be very angry
this butt [__] it we're sharing and
we're weird
um I will occasionally go outside yeah
to pee standing up that's a difference
and I go like I am man now and I'm doing
something super rugged and yeah you know
that is a special thing Val is in the
bathroom just this morning and I really
had to pee and I briefly was like do I
give myself the outdoor Glory right do I
give myself there's a national lyric
actually I think it's on the lvi it's
Matt burninger from the national and he
says um there's a lyric about his dick
being in sunlight and not being like the
greatest thing and I was like so good
yeah there really is something special
about just like outdoor oh yeah I almost
did that that I'm glad I still have
because that's the correct use of
outdoor pee I also just love that you
can do it without disrupting like like
any FL like flow like Val and I are
talking I'm just sitting on peeing and
it's not it's not even really
acknowledged it's no it's like it's like
the thing it's like a lesbian
relationship yeah basically I mean we
watch Blossom at night we're both
sitting to pee we love chatting more
than I love like layering the toilet is
mine in the animal kingdom yeah
yeah I love but I love that you
as a symbol like you've become like a
masculine everyone expects me to admit
that I love the already a great episode
for me that you join me in the
celebration of it it's listening it's
okay I think it's I think that there's
some part of me that at home yeah yes
this isn't that home thing it seems to
me to be more hygienic you know there's
of course less Splash happens of course
of course you know it seems to be the
trouble of raising and lowering a seat
it it's the Lazy Man's Choice it's also
just the smart man's choice and once I'm
in the wild if I'm in like a park
bathroom or something it's it's a it's a
joy to not have to press my hands on
that disgusting porcelain sure that's
that's what it's for sure God knew what
he was doing he's like surely the male
of the species will still sit to urinate
unless he's in a park bathroom that's
why the options right where even if I
had to go number two it would crawl back
up inside me at the side of a public
bathroom we're not doing it we're not
doing it that is so funny here's my I
did want to know about Florida but now
I'm thinking about this
we're not doing the Ethan soup play like
tell me about your journey like I it
exists people can find your
[__] Journey the Journey's out
there here's what I want but but here's
what I want to know and a little bit of
my
um appreciation of your journey is baked
into the question is you've become a
person and I told you this when I did
your podcast but like when I don't want
to work out and everybody knows it's
embarr I always say it's embarrassing
because I'm new at it so it's it's
embarrassing to be new at something but
that I've in the past year started
lifting waves and sometimes I don't want
to and I think it's a really special
compliment that you're one of the
disembodied heads that floats in my
Consciousness it's a massive compliment
for me it is right yes yeah I hope you
because I don't want you to think it's
weird I'm trying to say you've become an
avatar for like and imagine how many
thousands of people thousands of people
your chain the Ripple of this is huge
and then my I'd love to hear your
comment on that but I also want to know
who are the disembodied heads floating
around because
uh one last little thing you and I were
on set [__] Pepperidge Farm
[__] goldfish every goddamn
wear Skittles and loose Skittles and
bowls [__] you loose it is not done it
is today it's like sobriety it's today
yeah Ethan simply did something great
but it's today and I want to know a
little bit of the of the system that you
got going that keeps you on this path
yeah the system uh many many years ago I
was very frustrated
um in life and and I mean like uh short
temper and annoyed and I had these ideas
of right and wrong in the universe and
um I I then started to like really look
into that like you know how do we
discover what is right and wrong in the
universe and it very quickly came became
evident that
it was all subjective and it and if it's
also and you know we now have like the
the great Pastor uh Will Harris Sam
Harris Sam Harris the great uh religious
Pastor Sam Harris who will say over and
over and over again we need we need we
need right and to me that's religious
that is a position which requires a
value which cannot be objectively right
or wrong but you know if I look at
everything as like this guy's talking
about chocolate ice cream and he likes
chocolate ice cream and he's insisting
that chocolate ice cream is the best and
that we'll all do better as a species if
we just eat chocolate ice cream
I don't give a [__] about chocolate ice
cream to be honest with you I'm a french
vanilla ice cream guy which is a flavor
it is a flavor it is it's not the thing
upon which by the way chocolate is not
vanilla ice cream added chocolate they
took the vanilla that's the flavor
different vanilla is a flavor and it's
clean it's and it's classy and it's fine
and like if you prefer chocolate that's
fine too I'm never gonna get angry at
somebody that tries to insist that their
flavor is better than my flavor and
you're applying that to right and wrong
as well I'm applying that to right and
wrong and so I've just been on this
journey of like what is actually right
and wrong for me and from that position
I can live my life with less friction
there's so much friction that has washed
away and I'll say this too Pete it's
something that I came to believe in
Prior that prior to it having any effect
on me do you know what I mean like I can
believe that seems correct and I'm still
a guy who's reacting emotionally to
things that I feel are not going the way
they quote unquote should be going yeah
um and and so these kind of um floating
heads are uh you know anyone from
Foucault who I thought was a really
interesting historian and sure there's
lots of stuff and with all these people
that I disagree with but then there's
some gems that he I don't know anything
I've never heard of fuku it sounds like
a skateboard company he's is that like
bro he's like a French philosopher and
and I would even look around at the
landscape of a lot of the really wacky
quote-unquote problems that I perceive
today and go they're his fault yes
tell me tell me everything well don't
tell me everything but we want to keep
it about you but give me a little
Foucault okay well like the the
um a lot of the identity stuff comes
from him and so there's and a lot of the
power Dynamic talk comes from him and so
there seems like societally to be this
insistence that um
we recognize identity as being real as
being objectively real right while at
the same time it is all born within us
you know and I'm not talking about
you are paler than a guy from Jamaica
that's less what I'm talking about
versus what you how you identify
yourself right and and
you know it's a a lot of it is um
how how we socially construct things and
then find truth in them later right and
gender stuff and all of that but
Foucault was just saying it's all
[__] I know and if it's all [__]
guy by the way that was on succession
last night I I don't want to interrupt
but they were talking about how the dad
seems so wise but they're like you seem
so wise but you're saying stuff and and
we're all afraid of you and then when it
turns out it's true we all go like well
look he was right but like like the fear
of you saying it's going to be that way
changes the what I'm saying is people it
has a profound effect outside of us yes
exactly they're saying like you is it
true or do you make it true because
everyone's terrified of you like and
then everyone goes in hindsight well it
must be true it's like on The Simpsons
where they go like hold this Rock This
Rock keeps away cougars do you see any
Cougars it's like well the rock works
it's like well what is really true and
what are we kind of imbuing with meaning
is that am I on the track I I think so I
it is it is and you know if we as a
group get together and agree something
is the way it is then it becomes that to
some degree you know what I mean like
yeah our currency is all kind of this
imaginary game that we play but because
we instill belief into it it then
becomes real right and and there's so
much belief that there's a military
behind it but like I was just Val and I
were just over coffee this morning going
like
any two groups of soldiers taken away
from the power structures away from
their generals and away from their
countries would just be individuals that
would go like people doing if you stop
shooting at me I'll stop shooting at you
and we can just stop this but you're
like talk about believing in something
like God and Country and all this stuff
that motivates people that wouldn't have
murdered otherwise to you know kill
another person it's a wild yeah no you
have those wonderful stories about World
War one where on like Christmas
Christmas play football that's what I
was thinking yeah and also it's also
from succession but there's that story
where the the power does didn't want
they had this idea that the slave should
wear a yellow marking on their shirt
this is also from succession and they go
don't do it because if they see how many
they are they'll rise up and and right
they joke on succession they say that
Zuckerberg told that Parable I don't
know I don't think that's true I think
they're just [__] with Mark
Zuckerberg which is kind of cheeky and
hilarious but that's what I see even in
a soldier situation it's like wait
you're you're the body of power right
the slaves or or whatever group it is
the the numbers have the power but like
ideas and I was just reading this in A
Course in Miracles this morning they
were like Illusions are as powerful as
the truth in in miscreating as as
creating and I was like whoa that's a
pretty bold statement a hundred percent
I I think that it it just is like what's
convincible who's selling it the best
right and and that and that becomes the
story we live our lives by right and
right the story I was living my life by
was
um gave all the power to external forces
and and it was just me going like oh no
it's all up to me it's entirely up there
that was the shift that was the show
claiming your autonomy claiming my
autonomy and not allowing my belief
system that the external forces were in
control to dictate my life anymore so
it's like not be a victim it is a little
bit I mean it is you know I like I I
think about
I think about the cultural currency of
victimhood now and I think that like you
know we I I think it's very hard to tell
somebody don't be a victim right you can
tell yourself right it's words you use
for yourself I wouldn't I wouldn't tell
someone that's not my right
yeah I wouldn't go to a person because
if you would come to me when I was at a
state when I was like everything's
happening to me and I have no power and
no control and you and you just said
well stop your boots yeah yeah it
doesn't work in fact I would I I was
telling you the things we rebel against
remember I told you I have a bit where I
was like off pornography and after the
show somebody was like stay strong I'm
also a pornography each kind of struck
me as like a not a weird guy but like I
didn't want to be in his group and that
night I went home and looked at
pornography and part of the joke was I
didn't even want to no that's honest I
wasn't horny it wasn't about being horny
and we do that with food too sometimes
it's not about in fact it's almost never
about food it's about some sort of
I don't want to belong to a group or I'm
My Own Boss or I deserve whatever I want
or nobody tells me what to do like all
of this [__] up stuff that you're
following sorry so and and the victim
thing is also it wouldn't help if
somebody said Pete you're not even
making choices you're just reacting to
realities that aren't even there anymore
you're reacting to something that
happened when you were seven right that
would make me go [__] you and I'd eat
more goldfish yeah [__] you watch this
yeah [__] you watch this yeah [__] you
watch this keep so so you wouldn't say
that but you I I there's your own choice
or whatever yeah and again I don't think
there's any
you know like I like these guys who are
like be tough you know I like them I
react well to them but like I I don't
think that has the effect on me prior to
my coming to understand myself so I
don't think it's useful I don't think
it's like universally useful it's useful
if it works for you I think whatever
whatever success we have is useful
because we had success with it but like
this idea that well it must just
everybody should do this uh that doesn't
make any sense it's like drill sergeants
it's like this is gonna sound like a
joke but there are people who ring the
bell in the seals because they don't
respond to someone calling them a maggot
I I know that sounds like a joke if he's
going to be a Navy SEAL he should be
able to withstand verbal abuse different
things motivate different people Kumail
told me the story I believe he told it
on this podcast that when he was really
going for his rippedness his trainer
Camille couldn't do the whatever he
couldn't get it up the 10 time and his
trainer went one of his trainers went
pathetic and Kumail was like we're not
doing that like I had to call it out
it's just funny to me that in the
Marines or the Nate or you you can't go
like can we try a different like there's
different brains there's different
psyches and there's different emotional
response systems I happen to be one of
those people that goes work out and and
res and go through the resistance and
motivate yourself to like this morning
getting in the cold plunge because it
will make you feel fantastic you'll have
a better podcast with Ethan he'll have a
better day you'll be more available to
your daughter it's not and I'm not
making fun of Joe Rogan I don't tame my
inner [__] that that language doesn't
always work for me although I'll say out
of the other side of my mouth sometimes
I'm in the tub and I want to get out and
I'll hear Joe's voice say tame you're in
a [__] and it does work right no I'm
just not playing beta male and going
like that doesn't work sometimes it does
sometimes sometimes sometimes I need
something a little bit more new on just
a little more gentle me too and I've
found that if you are actively within
this belief system of [__] is happening
to me that I think to get out of it is
probably a more gradual approach to like
what can can you tie your shoes okay
that's not happening to you let's start
with what you perceive to be within your
control and work our way gradually out
and if one day you can go like oh well
it's everything that is occurring to me
is within my control that's wonderful
but it might take a number of years it's
not just a guy on Instagram going fight
through the pain and logic doesn't work
either it's like quit smoking it gives
you cancer that doesn't work no it
doesn't work they know in fact
unconsciously it's part of the appeal
it's like [__] you death like I don't
give a [__] that's why it's the
motorcycle of activities you're you're
burning down death it doesn't logic
doesn't work go ahead no whenever we
think about like when when when we when
I hear about the arguments against being
obese from like the mainstream like well
uh health health is the biggest one get
out of here so unhealthy I'm like
[__] drive race cars people
jump out of airplanes for fun you know
what I mean we get tattoos we smoke
cigarettes like there's so much
that's a bit it's like why aren't the
people that are so hard on the heavy
people on heavy and go like it's just
because I care about your health yeah
[__] you dude it's because there's a
fundamental self-love issue in you
there's there's an overweight not always
I'm I'm obviously saying this can be me
there's a very soft Junior High boy in
me that I can't tolerate and therefore I
will make fun of Brendan Fraser and the
whale I'm not saying I do I'm just
saying sure that's why you see people
say Free Willy when they see when I was
a kid you see a big kid at the pool I
used to get some free Willies that's
because you can't tolerate your own
fallibility your own your own when I say
softness I don't mean body softness I
mean your own vulnerability your own
mortality so so but to finish your bit
that if if you ever do stand up it's
ready to go it's like
if you really cared about People's
Health you would go and stop people from
skydiving or stop them from driving I
mean it's it's completely irresponsible
from a health metric right driving a
motorcycle if if the if we were all just
motivated by what is the healthiest we
can live motorcycles Stout they're done
you can't have one they are so unhealthy
also just uh air travel or or fine
dining right all killing ourselves we're
just doing it the the heroes of our
culture are doing it more exotically
more luxuriously oh I ate a 72 ounce
steak at The Big Texan because I'm
living life food travel shows are
someone saying watch me murder myself
watch me die I'm gonna eat pork face
Tacos on a street card in Malaysia watch
we're all dying I'm dying better than
you're dying right and you can pick your
favorite one and put it on your bucket
list right yeah where was the my
favorite place that Bourdain went who
had to medicate himself to continue
eating that way by the way he did was on
all kinds of statins or of course all
kinds maybe it was just one what's a
Statin it uh reduces it basically it's
like blocks the portion of your liver
that creates like LDL cholesterol oh
right a preventative cholesterol it's a
preventative cholesterol thing but it
there's like a lot of bad you know I
think
um of course the of course it's a hazard
of his job yeah wearing a bulletproof
vest if you're gonna keep eating deep
fried pork every day for your job you
got it yourself get involved and be like
we need to block some of this from
getting into your bloodstream right and
by the way the pill has side effects
it's not just like sunshine and Glory
you can take this pill and eat whatever
you want it puts a tax on your liver so
like we're we're [__] with the
systems to be able to get away with this
and I look at people's smoking
cigarettes and I'm envious I'm like that
[__] has it made he doesn't give
a [__] yeah he's smoking cigarettes he's
enjoying life yes and like I could also
look at an obese person and think the
same thing that dude got to go to
McDonald's today
you know what I mean so like what
there's a a Colin Hay song that he's
sober expresses the same sort of the
jealousy of the sober person which is so
important to stay in touch with lest we
get honor lest lest we get on our high
horse it's very healthy and I'd love to
hear you speak on this to go like no I
am jealous instead of going into addict
thinking and going no that's evil that's
evil what they're doing because then
you're just projecting it onto them and
hating them and that that's a medication
that has side effects
I I am jealous of my wife on a on a
weekly basis my wife drinks and she's
the person who leaves half a glass of
wine
and I'm looking at it going like that's
six dollars worth of wine you're just
gonna leave but I don't mind if you
leave 18 worth of steak but you cannot
leave six dollars worth of wine in the
glass this is unacceptable
um and I I was just thinking sorry keep
going
I just go like once you're feeling good
and this is why I'm a self-diagnosed
addict I'm always clear that I'm like
nobody else has told me that it's just
me
once I'm feeling good I'm like why
wouldn't you want to just keep going
like why wouldn't you want to just keep
going like you drink a Manhattan drink
it fast right drink it fast because that
people that ceiling water gets better
yeah of course it doesn't work like my
way doesn't work but every single time
I'd go it's worth a shot and every one
out of I don't know 50 you'd be in such
an amazing Peak state in your body in
your emotional life that the alcohol
would dance with that feeling it didn't
create it but it sort of like didn't
squash it so you'd be convinced that it
was the alcohol and then the next time
you're chasing that Dragon but when I
have this very vivid memory of being at
dinner
with my friends at gunters and Val and
they got Manhattans and they sipped
those [__] they were you said
the money it's funny the devil my devil
will go it's not going to be cold in
three right no that was that was as that
was as sane and as rational like I was
trying to make an argument for her you
know what I mean like for me it's just
like that glass of wine is a shooter you
need the bottle yeah and you get it in
your system as quickly as possible but
like when I'm when I'm making these
arguments I'm trying to go like how do I
make her finish the glass of wine do I
explain to her because about the
electrical bill you know because we ran
the hot tub too many times well it's the
money finished you gotta drink the wine
but the steak I don't give a [__] about
right you're back to we're back to
people pretending that they care about
People's Health when really they don't
they're really in some cases I'm saying
what I would be doing projecting their
hate outward and and being intolerant of
that in themselves and then it's and
then you're doing it with this with
money you don't really care about money
I don't give a [__] the money is
completely irrelevant how do I make an
argument that will win her yeah because
that's all it is I just want her to do
what I would have wanted to do and how
do I get her there and it's why it's not
the same argument for her this is tricky
stuff because so when we were in Canada
we've I've already talked about this on
the podcast but I hurt my neck I think I
told you I motorboated the shower spray
because it was a cold shower and I was
like I'm gonna really live life and I'm
going to motorboat the shower spray and
I hurt my neck and back just going I I
haven't done it on stage but I'm like
that means I can't motorboat my wife
that means if I want a motorboat my wife
I have to sit on the edge of the bed
like
like old husband and she has to move
like a car wash I have to be stationary
and she can drive me like a car wash but
I'm too old to go
which is literally the first thing you
do in life it's what babies can do I
can't do it anymore but then I hurt
myself
and I'm in Canada and they were like you
should take this Canadian muscle relaxer
this just goes back to money this goes
back to excuses we make Freedom right
Liberty I don't want to belong to your
weird Group pain is such a good one pain
is such a good one that I I I only took
one for three days but I was like this
is dangerous for me because I really
like the way it feels yeah and guess
what dude I'm six foot six I'm
constantly hurting myself all right
constantly and I was like I catch myself
Ethan I'm saying this like at the
meeting I catch myself wanting to wake
up having slept badly like on the wrong
so I can take one and I'm not even that
I'm not even that hooked by these things
there's just this like there's a desire
there yeah yeah I know I just want to be
a magic boy and feel feel good all the
time feel good all the time even though
it doesn't [__] work we all know it's
gonna lead to needing too it's gonna
need to needing three then Val was
joking she's like then we're in the
weird Canadian muscle relaxer phase of
our lives and you have to withdraw just
to feel normal you're taking random gigs
in Canada just to visit the pharmacy
yeah but facts and if you have that
built-in excuse that the excuse the
excuse what did what did that make you
think of I I've had a number of
surgeries since I been sober and there
was a time many many years ago where
uh you have a surgery and you take the
pills they give you and then I as an
addict am like explaining that I'm a
large guy and so I need a double dose to
get around my large system and I'm and
you start down the road of addiction
stuff which is so dangerous for me but
then it got to the point where my wife
was like hey that was crazy your
recovery from that where you were like
calling for more refills of a pill that
you had 30 days worth on the second week
you know so that's that's not okay they
had like like a squirrel I'm not even
trying to be funny I relate so hard I
get it you're like okay I have it now
but it it has gotten to the point where
I'm now having full-blown meetings with
anesthesiologists before I have a
surgery and and going like you may not
give me opiates and they're like well
every my you know they all have their
different protocols but he goes I you
know I give fentanyl while you're
unconscious but I won't give you any
when you're awake I have to say like no
you can give me ketamine instead of
fentanyl it [__] with receptors in my
brain I'll wake up like hungry for
opiates yeah um of course because you
were still there just because Ethan
wasn't there going like wow this is
great it was your body That's right The
receptors in your brain and body we're
still given and they remember they of
course they remember that's their job
yeah yes
um so I've also gotten to be uh quite a
bit better with pain you know like just
like the last surgery I had I I ruptured
my bicep I had to have it you know
drilled they drilled holes in my forearm
and cut me open and drag the bicep
tendon out and drill it into my forearm
and I I had um the doctor likes to wake
you up and check to see that you can
move your stuff and so they can't they
can do a nerve block but they can't do
it you can't move your arm if you have
the nerve block so they put the catheter
into the it's called the brachial plexus
it's this like bundle of nerves in your
shoulder and they put the catheter in
there and then once you wake up and they
and show the guy like I can move my arm
they then give you the juice to kill
your arm and then you can't move your
arm for a couple of days but it doesn't
hurt right
um them putting this nerve block in
prior to surgery the feeling the
sensation like when the catheter touches
this nerve bundle my whole body like
leapt out of the hospital bed it was
like the single biggest jolt of pain and
then it's over it's not like a lingering
pain it's just like like electricity to
your central nervous system yeah it's
like you were a fish and someone dropped
a toaster in yeah yeah serious so they
go like okay that's fine I have the
surgery I don't get given opiates thank
God I wake up I still groggly say give
me some Demerol and my wife is there to
go he's you don't don't do that
um you know and then I I come to a
little bit more and uh uh they go like
check my arm I move it and and I'm like
this really hurts please juice up that
catheter so I can not feel this pain and
the guy goes to do it and he
accidentally pulls the catheter out oh
God and at that point I just went like
you know what I'm just gonna go home and
Pace a lot until this stops hurting
because like I don't want to go through
that single jolt of pain again and it's
not so bad can I deal with this for a
day or two that's really real that's
like that's like putting an idea I want
this to a test do you want it so badly
that you have to withstand this horrible
pain again yeah and the answer is no
that's no like I want to feel good I'd
love to hear your thoughts on this
because we you and I talked a lot about
getting addicted using our attic nature
to get addicted to good things yeah and
when the ant the question is do you want
to feel good for me if I have anxiety
breath work is a really quick way to get
rid of that but man it's so [__] hard
sometimes it's actually impossible
meaning I don't do it to just go suffer
and then feel good catheter and then
you'll get your your juice and I often
will just tap out I guess what I'm
saying and I'd love to hear a comment
about human beings I think this is Tony
Robbins will do more to avoid pain than
they will to gain pleasure should you
talk about that yeah the the the thing
that helps me the most is like as a
sober person quite often I have to
remind myself
um and this is multiple times a day on
some terrible days that what I'm feeling
is temporary and that it will get better
and then you know I've even said that
like to somebody else to one of my kids
and my wife was like don't tell them
that there's no evidence that it's gonna
get better they could be you know and
I'm like
all right but we got to be hopeful too
right like there's got to be some hope
in there but to counter that I
understand that we don't know what's
going to happen in the future right even
if you and I were in some horrible
post-apocalyptic situation where every
once in a while I'd be like this is
pretty cool of all the people to be
paired with I'm with Ethan right yeah
punch in radioactive dogs
it could be exciting like Cormac
McCarthy oh the road and it's like this
is an adventure yes for sure but even if
we're in a Dire Straits I'm saying and
things are really bad
even in the midst of a terrible day you
could get you could feel better briefly
isn't that really what you're saying
it's not circumstantial happiness a
chemical happiness you probably won't be
this blue right all the time and I take
it as like if I look back on my life and
I can go like lots of lows so many lows
but are there more instances where I'm
not this low than their that however I'm
feeling now yeah
um I have belief if it's a down moment
that it will I can ride it out and so in
that sense I think in terms of like
wanting to go to McDonald's or wanting
to have a drink or you know God forbid I
accidentally see a drug transaction
happening on the side of the road and it
gets me it just sticks in my head that's
where I could get that you know yes
right um and pain is the same way oh
this this pain is you know I can't
imagine people with actual chronic pain
if it just never goes away like that
must be really awful but that's not been
my experience with pain pain goes away
and so right I mean by the way to
survive this that was what got Kurt
Cobain on heroin I think is because he
had those stomach issues which I say
with compassion I'm not saying that to
be like oh yeah right yeah remind guy
like pain leads people to do these
things so when you're there was a lot of
that that that was true for me too with
uh I've instantly fell in love with
opiates because my feet didn't hurt my
back didn't hurt there was a lot less
literal physical pain just in living
life as a very large person that went
away and then it also seemed to give me
a little bit of a personality and I
could talk to people and like because
you weren't probably anxious right I
mean I wasn't anxious I wasn't thinking
about like what does that person think
of me as much it was like you know
because you're set look I'm not trying
to be funny I'm saying this is why
people drink alcohol it's because they
have a private little flame inside right
that's like what what's this guy gonna
do he can't take this private little
flame right you're warmed from the
inside yeah and that's honestly how I
felt on those Canadian muscle relaxers I
was like I kind of have a thing going on
right yeah by the way dude I was taking
one it's half the dose and I still was
kind of like I had a little secret right
and now I'm talking to this guy and he's
kind of annoying and I think he doesn't
like me but I'm like the flame on it's
still burning and as long as I get away
from him or or just smile yeah right no
I mean that's that was a lot of drugs
for me like it wasn't fun to do drugs
with other people doing drugs I'd much
rather do drugs in secret and then have
that secret I'm only in secret me too
I'm only in secret and I was only I know
I I don't need to give a caveat and be
like we're not celebrating I'm just
saying like it's a certain kind of
person that wants it
and wants people to not know I want
people to just think that I'm an easy
guy right like an easy Smiley laughy guy
yeah and really that's an intolerance of
some of my
um harsher emotions like I just don't
like I said to Val uh yesterday I was
like it's not that I don't like the dog
it's that I don't like that I don't like
the dog
like it's not that I do there's nothing
about the dog other than I have sound
trauma and he barks and he scares the
[__] out of me but like and I'm not
kidding when I say sound trauma that's
not like how people use it I mean like I
legit have that and but the the
overreaction that I feel towards
whatever it is if something makes me
angry
it's not just anger it then comes in
this flood of embarrassment sure I'm I'm
Mama's Golden Boy I'm the second born I
solve problems I don't create problems
and I'm certainly not like my scary ogre
dad who always seemed mad not always but
you know what I mean I'm not like that
so we're back to
intolerance when people are hard words
ourselves towards ourselves that's what
I mean that's why when we want to make
fun of uh Brendan Fraser or we want to
uh tell like my mom will just tell a
very heavy person to stop eating she's
just yeah wait that's like I don't know
what you call that
um it's an intolerance you can't stand
how you feel you're embarrassed and
you're ashamed and then these drugs one
of the things that it does for me is I'm
like
uh and and I'm speaking to you from a
place of clarity I don't like it and it
really doesn't work but it temporarily
gives me the feeling of like I feel nice
enough or numb enough it's really numb
right and we've blocked out some of my
intellect we've certainly blocked out my
ability to grow or to learn or to be
challenged or to truly connect which is
one of my big sobriety things is my
daughter will not see a glassy look in
my eye like right I could cry thinking
about that it's like that's not
happening like we'll do something
there'll be something she doesn't like
about me but it's not going to be dad
was like Hey Baby
it's not gonna be that yeah um but the
intolerance of the feeling go well
anything what do you got I I I I'm I'm
so with you on all of that stuff I I
think I think that it it it it it comes
down to like a lot of what I've
struggled with in my life is the feeling
of dissatisfaction with myself and so I
a lot of that for me was built upon
these perceptions narratives ideas about
how things should and shouldn't be yeah
and to get rid of that
I I've become happier I've become
mellower because nothing should be
anyway it is how it is and I can work to
better myself and allow other people to
have their preference and that's all I
really care about like I Ethan you're
nailing it it's beautiful I care very
much about everyone being correct with
even if it goes totally against
values I hold right because I haven't
disregarded my own values I have values
this is something my wife gets very
concerned with and goes like well if
it's all relative then there's no right
and wrong then how do you feel about X Y
and Z and I'm like I don't like it yeah
so that's something I like it's not
something I want to see happening you
know I don't like War I'm pretty opposed
to war yeah um but at the same time it's
like is it maybe necessary at times I
mean is violence sometimes necessary if
a guy breaks into my house I'm probably
not gonna lie still while he rapes my
wife you know I'm trying to get violent
and that's the value I choose and I
would also want to understand why are
you doing this dude like what's
happening with you right you know yeah
this is so interesting going back to
what you I was thinking because you and
I have talked about it before there's
the line in Shakespeare nothing is right
or wrong but thinking makes it so yeah
but what is really empowering without
getting your because your wife throws a
very legit at pickle our way and I know
what she's talking about because I
dabble in these types of thought
experiments as well but what I'm after
is a personal
um spaciousness and and I want to suffer
less than I want but I also want to
it's not just whistling in the dark it's
it's syncing up with nature in the way
that nature doesn't have the same this
is tricky like everybody knows we're
against bad things like you have to say
that we're against bad things but there
is something interesting about being
like don't worry about other people
um things are happening and you can't
really change everything that's
happening
you can change your response to those
things that's what I'm trying that's my
my biggest goal and also nature is a
real interesting one because every time
I look at nature you know like this
whole natural law the philosophy on
natural law with which basically our
country was founded to me there's
nothing natural in natural law the way
they describe it where men should have
dignity and this that doesn't exist in
nature nature is violent we'll cut to us
at our post-apocalyptic in fact
the post-apocalyptic thing we all are
aware that that you're like three meals
away from becoming like a different
person right and I think that's what
frustrates people when we get very Naval
Legacy I'm the most Naval gazy of them
all and I find a lot of value in it but
I see a lot of people that might have
different types of lives and they might
be struggling more going like must be
nice to be able to talk about those
things but if you follow that deeper I
think we're going into our lineage as
human beings and going like there's been
a lot of not dignified you know like
cavemen killing murder like killing
animals and eating them isn't really
dignified we've changed it we've been
like it's the middle of kings and we sit
at Banquets and you don't see the
slaughterhouse anymore right and you
don't see them I'm not this isn't a
vegan agenda in fact you know this Ethan
I've started eating more chicken because
I've been trying to get more protein
sure so I can't even claim that group
anymore and that's the worst part is I
really love that ethical jolt I'm just
kidding but like we we I already told
the story but in preschool in Lila's
preschool they were singing a song about
monkeys getting eaten by alligators but
it sort of hinted at and at the end of
the song one of the kids goes what
happened to the monkeys and everyone was
like they swam away they they ran away
and they got away and the teacher's like
yeah they got away and then Dean I've
been doing this on stage this one boy
Dean who I love Dean just goes they died
and then the teacher's like okay Dean
thank you and then Dean goes blood in
the water
[__] yeah I love Dean don't you [__]
love Dean even like to me art and
philosophy and and Theater and so many
things this conversation are trying to
go like
okay there's what we're creating as a as
an ideology and then it's built on the
back of a reality that doesn't really
understand what you mean when you say
human dignity yeah exactly or personal
dignity yeah they're they're one of my
kids brought me these these pictures of
of
um a town in Europe and it was I don't
know if it was World War One or World
War II and it was before and after the
war right and
and she was asking me if I could find
beauty in the after and and I was like
yeah to me that's a beautiful picture
and she was like but it's all there's so
much destruction and we've talked about
this Pete there's no
there's no creation without destroying
something that's nothing nothing
everything feeds on death yes yeah and
so I feel like there's you know I go
around American there's this attempt to
make everything static it just needs to
be this way and then it needs to stay
this way all inhale is what we call it
they want this
never exhaling never exhaling never
right and and that to me doesn't make
sense I I think we've got to see beauty
and Decay Decay is natural it's a part
you know and like [__] I don't put so
much emphasis on everything having to be
natural right because natural is murder
and rape and savagery that I don't want
to experience I don't want that I don't
want to be a part of a system that like
thrives on just you know the strong or
killing the weak that's gross to me too
but we're all gonna grow old we're all
gonna die [__] decays and is it can't
that be beautiful also it has to it ha
you have absolutely no choice you can be
in denial and be in Times Square
and briefly believe that by being and I
I'm saying this I've caught myself at
times being a consumer and being like
I'm going to live forever because I keep
buying this stuff that is like an
extension of me it's my iPad it's like
I've grown in size my car my house my
country my job and it's like no you're
still a daisy in the middle of a field
like you're right very very vulnerable
but every psychedelic experience not
everyone big profound ones Any jungian
Dream any sweat lodge vision is all
shouting the same thing this too shall
pass this will pass it's all passing
it's all to quote Jesus he says store
not I always do the King James because
it's what Romulus would say store not
your treasure where where rust and moth
doth corrupt right right so it's this
idea that you need to find something
purer and truer and eternal in you
because everything else
is is passing your joy is passing your
sadness is also passing you win and you
you have a moment of elation and then it
immediately starts fading yeah we need
to we need to reconcile blood in the
water blood in the water that's that's
truth make peace with it and go
it's okay not just I think you have to
forgive it you need to you need to look
at in the face and go like that's what's
happening not uh
uh endless plastic surgeries and right
when people are like look at Madonna and
share they don't age I'm like look I'm
not putting them down do your thing I
understand that's part of your business
but part of me is I'm like what are we
doing and as soon as they did you don't
we have a denial of death in this
culture we have no understanding of
Cycles or or to me when you're dying is
like the idea and you're already doing
it get over other people and get over
yourself a little bit if if you're the
center of the world and the whole thing
has been a movie about you and you're
dying no [__] [__] you're scared to
die dude right no [__] [__] the movie
The only thing you've ever been
interested in you is about to fade out
you'd be a dingus if you're gonna spend
your entire life that way and be cool
with that but if you're zooming out and
looking at your interconnectivity and
looking at something bigger and and
embracing the mystery and forgiving
reality then you can get over yourself
and and that's not as big of a
transition anymore yeah you know um
you're a parent and the the place where
I could touch this
ability was uh before I had my first kid
and I read the book you know
um What to Expect When You're Expecting
but this was that's very much from a
female perspective but I still I wanted
that knowledge I tried to get all that
knowledge and then the baby came and I
still felt like I don't know what the
[__] to do I don't know what to do and
then I'm rationalizing well people have
been doing this for millions of years
and and like I'm here so they figured it
out like nobody knows there's just the
the very similar to death by the way you
go well everybody dies it's everybody
yeah we've all been doing it yeah
nothing doesn't really strip it of
mystery the baby is still like what do
we do now you sell yeah for me it
required just the almost Cockiness to go
I got this right to to just to just go
like all the the nonsense that I that is
also true of like I don't know what to
do because I really [__] don't I'm
just going to behave as though I do know
what to do yeah and deal with problems
as they come up and
I've like that that was the first moment
that I felt like it's it's okay like I'm
okay now that I decided to be okay and I
touched that and never kind of lost it
with my kids and there will be times
where my kids come to me and say like I
wish you were there dad because you
always know what to do and I I go like I
don't know what the [__] any of this is
I don't know anything but they are
convinced because I can convince myself
around them that I got this when you're
with me you're safe I you're taking care
of you're protected all whatever it
means to be a father to me and then it's
it's happened more and more like you
know I got a flat tire and there's no
AAA and I've never changed a tire and
the [__] got no cell service and
there's uh 10 minutes of like a stomach
ache because I'm so stranded and so
the world is now imploding upon me to I
can I just decide I can do this and I do
it and I change a tire and it's not the
easiest thing but also people [__]
change tires you know what I mean yeah
yeah yeah and that's kind of
been the way I eventually got to this
thing of like whatever's happening with
me is on me yes and and I wouldn't I
wouldn't go around telling people you
have to be like this because I don't
believe that that's true but for me
that's what works that's so a friend of
mine just had a very profound Ayahuasca
situation and that was one of the things
it was like just you and he kept asking
it questions about other people and it
was like what is what are you what are
you doing
like how do you feel in this situation
and it kept stressing that everybody has
autonomy and everybody has has Choice
which is really beautiful I also love
what you're saying it's actually in The
Comedians in Cars episode where Seinfeld
somebody says something they're like
well what what if we go there and this
happens and he goes then we'll deal with
it right and it was like
those simple truths sorry to keep
mentioning drugs and as much as we've
been talking about sobriety but I had a
an MDMA experience where I was like it
brought me to tears the thought I was
like people don't have to be like me
neither side of that is and I don't have
to be like them yes that's like if you
could write that on a piece of paper and
eat it and have that get into yourselves
how many of your problems would just go
away and another one I'd like to write
on paper and eat is if that happens
we'll deal with it we I quote this all
the time anxiety is paying interest on a
debt That Never Comes you're just you're
just paying it's not the bill didn't
come yeah why are you worried you didn't
order it it's not at the table you
didn't need it yeah now this is
something I
um subscribe to wholeheartedly I I
believe that is truth and I still have
anxiety yeah and and these things uh I I
battle with Within Myself this is like
my final biggest battle or my most
recent or profound which is like no this
isn't real and yet I'm still have a
rapid heart rate you know I could
[__] have anxiety right now just
thinking about
if you and I because you're very
convincing about the cold stuff and and
and it still makes me scared and if if I
was to agree with you or or make oh my
God you know I because I think uh for me
the the highest level of truth that I
can achieve is agreement with someone
and and that goes down to like I told
Pete I would do this thing I have to do
it yeah you know yeah I'm not gonna not
do it because I told Pete I would do it
and then you are your own worth that
like and then I'm like until I do it
yeah but I know it won't be as bad as I
think it will be that's true and I can't
get out of that and so it does take some
time going
that's not real yes none of that's real
nobody feeling isn't real when I did
your podcast and even when we're talking
now this is a very special Pete this is
midday Pete you and I were talking about
like
in the morning
some time with my fam I have my first
coffee it's the most special Pete that's
the P that hosts the podcast yeah he's
great and I love him
um but like we're saying it's not always
that Pete and Val said about me she's
like in the course of the day you feel
every emotion she's like I I watch you
feel every single emotion and it's true
I've gotten very polite about it I'm not
like flailing around like Miss Piggy or
Kermit with my arms like this I'm not
like that but I am internally I'm
feeling everything what one of the
things you just said I was thinking
about like so you take Ayahuasca right
Ayahuasca is one of those things that
I'm like people talk about it being so
intense and so
frightening and life-changing and and
it's it's the opposite of an escape drug
it's like the most confronting like hey
have you noticed that you do this and
I'm going to show you it for four hours
you know yeah you really you come out
like broken and then it rebuilds you
it's not it doesn't sound like taking
Molly at Lollapalooza you know what I
mean we're just like let's cuddle let's
cuddle exactly it's not that it's not
that at all and I but yet I remain
interested in it and and this is you and
um
anxiety by the way what I was going to
say was nighttime Pete I'll wake up and
pee and I'll have to ward off just
generalized my brain is a master at
finding something to be like did that
upset somebody right did you just stay
awake yeah yeah you need to stay awake
you need to grind on this and I will go
my bathroom mirror is covered in all
these quotes that I love and most of
them are about how all reality is mind
and like you've never separated from God
and all these mantras like one of my
favorite lines is myself rests safely in
the mind of God even if you're in the
most dangerous situation where you are
in reality is where you've always ever
been here and now in the Eternal and the
placeless place of what we could call
God or the mind of God so you've never
been in danger in your life uh tell that
to 3 A.M 3 A.M
3 A.M Pete tells you to go [__] yourself
that's what I'm gonna think about what I
said lunch to that guy yeah and that's
where vowel so Val is I told you this
she's the great counterpart to my
headiness she's all body so she's
somatic and she's like you got to put
your hands on your chest get get some
weight on you uh you told me Splash cold
water on your face helpful things I
breathe and and that's that small step
even though you think it's not gonna
work can you take one deep breath just
one like you were saying can you tie
your shoes just one deep breath but this
I had two thoughts going at the same
time the other one was
so I'm interested in doing something
like Ayahuasca and even though I've told
you I'm an addict I'm California sober
which means I'll occasionally take a
small edible of weed and I got a little
paranoid and listen to The Genius of
this paranoia because there was nothing
wrong everything was fine I wasn't like
where's my daughter she was sleeping
where's Val everything everybody's fine
circumstantially fine my brain my genius
brain went not me but something in there
was like you want to do
Ayahuasca you are the biggest threat to
us like it was like right who are the
danger yeah like you want to be afraid
of something be afraid of you yeah you
keep signing us up for uh fattening
foods you keep signing us up for you
drive to La all those times all that
time on the freeway uh you want to do
incredibly uh unstable or unpredictable
sacred medicines like you're [__]
this up we keep telling you to just stay
inside it's like it's like the voice of
my savior yeah be safe it was my fight
flight going like the Call's coming from
inside the house dip [__] like you think
you need to protect yourself from other
people it's all you it's all of you
it's all us no no matter what
I know that's that's probably the voice
telling you to stay awake like right
like that might be that but it's also
it's not lying no it's not it's not that
actually the the other side of that coin
is power yeah it's like on this side
it's fear it's all you what are you
doing and and shame and embarrassment
gets in the way and on the other side is
oh [__] it's all me yeah it's all me I
can I can do whatever I want which
brings me I had a couple specific things
oh God I wrote down so many things I
want to say but I'm gonna I'm gonna pick
this one when you're in a way where
you're having a rough day and you can't
find the motivation to do something big
like a one-hour workout or two whatever
you're doing
what is there something that you do
mentally physically that can just a tiny
gain that might get the ball rolling
yeah it's it's specific to me because I
don't know if anybody else has
experienced this but have you ever had a
dream
um or have you woke up and you can't
move like there's a there's a Val has a
sleep paralysis yeah sleep paralysis so
the only way and and I actually had as
an aside a bad drug experience where I
went into actual paralysis
um we used to me and my buddy used to we
can do a side drug stories right yeah
yeah
um me and my buddy used to buy drugs
from the VA down on Wilshire in West
Westwood
and basically we we met a nurse there
who would buy prescriptions once they
were filled from vets so vets could take
the money and go get the street drugs
that they were doing instead of the
[__] prescription drugs we hadn't
quite graduated to the street drugs yet
we were still onto prescription drugs
and he sold us a bottle of this stuff
which I believe was called chlorohydrate
it had a big red sea on it which means
it's controlled substance and it just
looked like a a cough syrup but it was
bright green and and he said just take a
half a cap cap full of this and then
wait a long time and we did that and
then nothing happened so we filled up
the capsule and took them this is a Wolf
of Wall Street basically the movie
you're in me and my friend were frozen
for a number of hours two months wait it
kicks in it kicks in and you're Frozen
just drool completely completely alert
cannot move
oh just stuff and and it didn't feel it
wasn't like God this feels wonderful
like heroin you get you get high on
heroin and you maybe aren't moving
because you're just in one you're having
a fine time yeah this was you were a
muppet and the hand was taken out the
hand was taken out and I'm like I'm a
big guy too and I suffer from like I
can't sit still for very long because
the weight on that section of my body
will begin to cause it to die I think
you need it I'm not trying to be funny
you need to rotated yeah yeah no
rotation and I'm feeling like oh it just
it was horrible but I have had dreams
and woken up did it just where I just
wore out it wore off it took like four
or five you like wiggled a finger and
you're like it was [__] thing yeah
coming back and then your whole body you
came back first
me I came back first and I shook him a
little bit and he like uh and we're
drooling it was off gosh it was [__]
awful but I I do wake up sometimes with
a panic of like I got that that's
happening again yeah and the only
way to for me to get out of it is to you
know you almost jolt yourself you like
take a deep breath and like put if if
getting out of bed requires a two of
energy you gotta put a 10 into just yep
shocking you're jump starting yourself
yeah yeah it's a jump start so I will
have to do that
multiple times a week where
if I'm awake and laying in bed and
that's not actually occurring but I
suddenly don't want to go to the gym I
don't want to get up I don't want to eat
the food I've meal prepped I don't want
to do my writing I don't want to do all
the things that keep me as focused and
happy as I can possibly be it does
require a bit of me mentally going
[__] go right and that's when I can
summon those guys Joe Rogan
um David Goggins Cameron Hayes who who
seem to do all of this through pain the
pain I'm experiencing isn't that I'm
running an ultra marathon on a broken
leg the pain is I am uh apathetic
towards life or experiencing Melancholia
or depression or whatever it is that has
me stuck that's my version of I gotta
fight through this and and I got and and
that's and that's what I do I literally
imagine I've just woken up and I have
sleep paralysis and I have to jolt
myself awake wow so that that physical
condition is has primed you to know like
okay this is one of those things yeah I
saw so my YouTube has figured out that
I'm getting interested in stuff like
this so it keeps showing me like Jim and
fridge and all that sort of stuff right
and Paul Rudd had one and you know he
got real ripped for Ant-Man and one of
them was like I forget exactly what the
quote was but essentially it was like
there's like motivating yourself which
is like finding a reason to do it
and then he's like but that's that's not
it doesn't work he's like you can't like
wait to find a reason and get a reason
he's like it's just to do it it's it's
just uh I hate this and I'm gonna do it
and I'm like that seems like a muscle
that you can work on question mark
I think it's exactly the same with you
however awful your cold plunge was today
you know it's going you know well you
had the effect the effect your shoe you
you got and you know that you're gonna
build up some tolerance to it
it's exactly the same for me with
working out I uh five times out of ten I
don't really want to go and do it I'm
only doing it because I know the rest of
my day will be better yeah and then if I
get into a routine of it it's actually
more difficult to not do it because I'm
just now accustomed to doing it but if I
take a week off which this last week I
think I only got to the gym once because
we were working and then I had something
else to do over the weekend and I only
just got home
but I went to the gym today and I was
like I'm gonna start off with legs which
is the [__] worst and it was so hard
and so awful and I I was actually doing
much less than I had been doing two
weeks before because my legs are now
suddenly they're not out of shape
they're going to be fine in a week or
two but they were just like no wait a
second wait we're not doing that anymore
you know right right and so I did that
and I walked out of the gym with a pep
in my step and feeling great and and I
could experience the sun where prior to
that the sun was harmful to me yes yes
it was great so I just kept doing that
one foot in front of the other I love
that and that when I got out because
sorry this is how I can relate yeah
you're right I got out of the co-point I
didn't want to do it was first thing in
the morning which is the hardest is
because you just got out of the bed and
you're all cooked like a hot dog and you
get in but I my daughter was kicking me
all night and I just slept like bad and
I just needed reboot I needed to lick a
big old nine volt battery like a big one
yeah and when I got out it this seems
like a YouTube video but I went I
already won like that's what I said I
was like I already won but this is what
here we're gonna go to the mid-rolls but
we kind of were talking about this
earlier
Peak State people Pete that's standing
in the sunlight glistening and cold
going I've already won yeah he's not the
best guy to give advice
to anybody like Peak State what's
interesting is the let's talk a little
bit more about that yeah because I wrote
that down I was like non-peak State
people 500 pound Ethan
I want to know what he needed because
it's not Pete going I've already won
that just seems like a guy with a hot
girlfriend being like and the best thing
is you do it all the time right like it
doesn't help so let's get to that we'll
be back in literally two minutes three
minutes we'll be right back
whenever I buy something I always do my
research especially if something I'm
going to put inside of my body because
doing research before you buy something
means making better and more informed
choices especially when it comes to
stress or Sleep Products like CBD and
that's where next Evo Naturals my
favorite new CBD brand knocks it out of
the park which isn't always the case a
study by an independent lab recently
confirmed that some Brands contain up to
60 percent less CBD than they claim on
the label but with next Evo you can
trust you're getting the best of the
best they use smart sorb technology
which is proven to have 30 times better
absorption in the first 30 minutes and
four times the overall absorption as
other products so for people who don't
have taken CBD in the past and just
don't get what it's about don't feel it
don't notice it smartsorb is here and
makes a huge difference so if you've
written off CBD in the past next Evo is
an absolute reimagining it's a game
changing wonderful thing the stress
gummies is what I take almost every day
that's their CBD and their whole plant
ashwagandha which is an adaptogen these
are Lifesavers when I'm feeling
overwhelmed or anxious if I'm just
stressed and can't get on with my day
can't face my inbox can't handle company
coming over these are my secret weapon
to round the edges and get me back to
feeling ready to face my day so if
you've tried CBD before and you didn't
get it didn't like it trust me next Evo
is different give it a try upgrade your
CBD and show your support for this show
go to next evo.com weird to get 20 off
your first order of 40 or more that's 20
off 40 bucks or more at
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com slash weird also
brought To Us by our friends at Sunday
lawn care if you're like me you love
spring but you may not love figuring out
how to take care of your yard does
anyone else just stand and the line in
the in the aisle in the store wondering
where to start feeling overwhelmed
feeling anxious well that's where Sunday
lawn care comes in Sunday is everything
you need to get the lawn you've dreamed
of this spring go to get sunday.com
weird and enter your address to get a
customized plan created just for your
lawn it's really really cool no trips to
the store or Heavy Hauling bags since
they ship straight to your home plus you
just need a hose to apply Sunday it's
actually fun it's actually easy you can
fertilize your whole lawn in less time
than it takes to watch an episode of
your favorite TV show and they only use
ingredients you can feel good about that
means no harsh chemicals no long waiting
periods or trying to keep your kids and
pets off the lawn simply apply let it
dry and you're back to enjoying your
yard best of all Sunday is easy and
affordable some lawn care services cost
more than 1500 a year but Sunday's full
season plans start at just 109 nine
dollars and Sunday is offering on on top
of that our listeners get 20 Off full
season plans started just 109 and you
can get 20 off when you visit
getsunday.com weird at checkout just 109
bucks get 20 off when you visit
getsunday.com weird twenty percent off
your custom plan getsunday.com weird
show your support for your lawn and for
this show all right everybody let's get
back to Ethan suplee
and we're back we're back
um I you know the you talked about the
disembodied heads that are motivating to
you one of them for me is myself at 500.
I was actually curious that was one of
the ones I wondered if he was there he's
there and his his state was just
that you can't do anything there that
the world is happening to you and you
can't do anything and and how do we
experience as much pleasure right this
second as possible because there's
there's nothing else to be done and so
just recognizing that as an association
between the more base urges I have is
super helpful to me in going like I'm
motivated to not get back to that
because you know and it has nothing I
mean broke out of a prison I'm not
saying everybody's a prison I'm just
saying yeah it's like when you break up
with somebody and I I wonder how this
informs like things like cheat days and
stuff it's like you break up with them
then you have to like stay broken up
it's like a new state it's like stay
broken up but I was always very good
I've never gone back to a girlfriend
because I was like you hated breaking up
with them you hated losing 300 pounds it
was not fun yeah yeah it's not fun so
it's almost like now you're in the does
this make sense the honoring what you've
already done totally 100 and and you
know like cheat days I don't I don't
really do cheat days but I like fast
food is generally off limits that's just
like you know for me [__] you chicken
Big Mac yeah but I mean we had that
moment there they I don't know if they
even have them here they're certainly
not advertising like they were maybe
it's a Toronto [__] chicken Big Mac I
want to try that you know there's some
part of me that gets really antsy when
it's McRib season and you're like I
don't even think I like that sandwich
when it was when I could eat it but
shamrock shake they know what they're
doing they know what they're doing
they're going so well it's uh it's
designed
um scarcity like diamonds yeah yeah
we're oh we don't have diamonds yeah you
do so so for me sobriety is some some
rules that are absolute for myself right
and and and like I'm envious of my wife
who drinks and is never driving home
drunk is never getting into a fight it's
never blacked out it's never tripping
and twisting her ankle because of
alcohol is never trying to burn her life
down is never sneaking off to the crack
house after a couple glasses of wine
right that's not what she does and so I
have jealousy and then I see people who
I consider alcoholics
um who have said to me at in times like
I'm an alcoholic who I've gone like yeah
I agree I agree with you you have a
problem and and then if you were waiting
for me to say nah right no yeah it's not
gonna happen and then I've I've
experienced those people saying I don't
have a problem anymore and I've I've
gone okay but in my head I've gone I
don't know about that dude and then
watching them drink or use drugs I'm
judgmental of not openly but I I feel
that I feel like that's a dangerous path
that person's on
um the beer and wine only Pat it's just
right it's just beer and wine I could
drink a lot of beer dude yeah yeah
um but for with food I have to have you
know it's it's a very it's a slightly
more complicated because you don't quit
eating right I just don't do drugs and I
try to stay away from places that the
drugs I liked are being taken you know
like I'm not opposed to going into a
hospital and half the people there are
doped up on morphine that's fine
um it's not the setting that I would
think of as like let's get high on
heroin or something right so um will you
stay away from other places where
everyone's high on heroin right yeah or
whatever yeah yeah yeah whatever
whatever yeah I I don't even really like
bars my wife uh likes to have alcohol
with dinner which is fine but like
meeting people at a bar to hang out with
them I can do that and I'm not like
risking my sobriety but it's not really
fun for me watching people get drunk no
um that's the first thing you notice is
you're like oh you know you're all drunk
and I'm I'm drinking of soda but also
that they're insufferable that was what
I met as I was taking a break from
drinking and you asked me if I was sober
and I was like oh interesting I think
that might have been one of the first
times I considered oh yeah you can just
not go back yeah right instead of like
constantly burning it all the way and
then taking a month off except for
October okay come on food is tough
because we we don't quit eating
um yeah but like I have my uh guard
rails which are things that I don't go
beyond which one is I don't eat in
secret I'm not gonna eat if it's crazy
the wife to watch it I just said to
myself I was like if you just made a
rule you know there's there's other
things like this if you just cooked all
your meals you would lose this weight
because nobody's like deep frying like
it's just not you don't have the
technology to make it as in fact I used
to have a bit about like we go to
restaurants because we want them to cook
for us in a way that we would never do
exactly more butter but like we if you
were doing it and don't tell me about it
I don't want to say the calories just
exactly keep it behind closed doors it's
like you put a hit out on a chicken I
don't want to know I don't wanna yeah
just bring it out when it's done and
then the other what was I saying [__]
what was I saying uh oh I was like if I
just said you can't eat alone right like
it would be over because I'm a social
guy I like I have
functional shame so I'm not gonna
necessarily like when when I was eating
those goldfish on set tell me if this
doesn't sound like an alcoholic it does
I would go to crafty I'd open one eat
the whole thing at crafty take another
one and walk back with that one this is
the one I'm eating yeah you didn't see
the one I shot like an oyster shirt
right that's Michael J fox had that
sobriety story it's like you'd go back
to the kitchen and fill his wine to the
same level like the the skill and the
Precision of the addict is is pretty
interesting and I also like I don't care
if one person sees me shoot the whole
bag right because who cares all they
know about is that one bag that's right
and they're a goldfish and then the
other goldfish I'm going over here it's
just it's just working with object
permanence like you don't know I'm not
bringing this to someone else all of
this it's like mobster stuff it's like
you did you see me eat it and I didn't
need it that's me I did that don't eat
don't eat in secret don't eat yeah alone
like that would help me a lot don't eat
alone yeah it was a loan for me but then
it's going to be tricky for you Pete
when you're on the road you're you know
what I mean so you you gotta you got but
but like the way I get around that is
like would I do what I'm doing in front
of Brandy my wife yeah yeah would this
be okay for her to see is this is this
something I'm not I'm not doing it in a
sneaky way you know what I mean because
I I have a I think we put things into
categories and so for me if I went like
I'm never gonna eat alone and then I
found myself traveling for a week alone
at some point I would go well I'm gonna
eat now and then the guard rails come
off and then I'm in the crack house you
know right you've gone you've broken the
seal yeah that's real attic stuff too
I'm like well I've done this I might as
well do a million other things that's
right I already ate the buffalo wings
I'm gonna order three desserts yeah can
I can I be can I honestly say you know
I'm not sneaking into our pantry to do
tablespoons of peanut butter
um
um and I'm and I've positioned myself so
nobody else can see I've got my back to
them and they're not seeing the waiter
put down just too much food in front of
me would I be willing to turn around and
have somebody watch me eat this meal
because I I don't like people watching
me I find that I'm I find it to be uh
that I eat in a disgusting manner I
think I get too fast and and it's gross
I'm with you that's that you told that
wonderful story wonderful it's a sad
story but look you wonderfully told a
vulnerable story on risk which I really
loved and I told you the part you were
trying to score and the part that I just
related to so hard was you're coming up
to a red light and you would stop before
the other cars because you didn't want
anyone nobody to see me yeah yeah that's
the voice right the the voice of my
addiction is like just stick with me
like just stick with me it's you and me
and it's you and me it's the reliable
it's dangerous other people are
dangerous yeah other people are
dangerous other people are in the way
they don't understand and then I I we
already hinted at this I have that voice
that's like you deserve it like you're
it's hard life is hard for you yeah and
then if you really really listen closely
I think it goes like and we're all gonna
die like you could die tomorrow yeah and
you want to eat this whole pizza right
yeah yeah like right but that that goes
back to blood in the water the way isn't
around it the way isn't even the other
direction it's through it you have to go
like yes I'm gonna die and life is not a
pizza no matter how many breadsticks
spilling out of a bag in slow motion
domino shows me we're facing a
formidable foe that's using our wiring
to be like yeah listen to that the
smallest earliest part of your brain
that tells you to eat fat and calories
whenever you can and then they put pop
music to it and Michael Jordan is
drinking a Pepsi like it's so it's a
wonder more of us and so many of us are
struggling with with food well that's
how I got sober I um I had uh I you know
I would go to bed just about every night
pretty convinced I was gonna die in my
sleep but it was a well it was a kind of
a like a gamble right it was a a a toss
of the roulette wheel and and if if I if
if like on a night like tonight me going
to bed equal death I give myself a uh
one number on that roulette like one in
36 right well when I was doing it was
red or black and heavy it was red or
black yeah oh no and I was basically
okay with that and then
I got told I had congestive heart
failure and what would happen is my feet
would swell and then my legs would swell
and then my thighs would swell and then
I'd get scared and I and I didn't I was
not diagnosed I'd just be like holy [__]
I'm gigantic as it is and to swell on
top of that and not be able to put on
pants was crazy and so I'd stop doing
drugs for a few days and the swelling
would go away and I'd go okay well I I
got I got so accustomed to just getting
dope sick every couple of weeks because
I had to stop because I wanted to get
rid of the swelling
um
and then I would start doing drugs again
and pretty quickly within a week or two
the swelling would start again and I it
got it went into my groin and started to
get into my abdomen and I went to a
doctor and the doctor said you have can
this is congestive heart failure and I
said so what do I do to handle this and
and the doctor said well if it was just
your feet and legs you could get off
drugs and you could survive but I'm
sorry to tell you like you're gonna die
like you have weeks what before you die
This is Gonna Keep moving slowly and
when this swelling reaches your heart
your heart can't beat anymore and you
die
and and it was this really weird thing
of like oh well now I'm really going to
die for sure I might as well get off
drugs and and I was actually it was it
was a just a weird experience of like
I'm gonna die I should stop doing that I
stopped doing drugs it was almost like
yeah for as a human being I didn't like
doing them I didn't like being a drug
addict and maybe if I know I'm gonna die
now I should go out with a little bit of
nobility a little bit of honor and that
was when I got sober that was like I I
went to rehab immediately and for the
third time but on it wasn't people
convincing me to go it was me going I
need to go to rehab I'm gonna go
straight my [__] out like a death scare
it was a but but it wasn't even a death
scare it was I I had death scares every
night this was a confirmation that
you've got a couple weeks and you're
gonna die wow yeah and you wanted to
don't let me put words in your mouth you
wanted to go out sober I wanted to go
out sober I wanted to I wanted to at
least go out fighting for something you
know like not just in this state that
was the first time that I it wasn't it
wasn't hopeful like if you do this
you'll survive it was this is the state
you're in and I just felt like I would
feel better about myself if I improved
my condition a little bit I'm not super
surprised again in my in my little
practice this morning I was thinking
about how like the pressure of death is
one of the things that can
um
spur spawn change it it's like some
people I think and I think I might be
one of them for the final step the final
like okay like no Foolin
comes when the gun is the metaphorical
gun is on your head and you're like okay
for real like what do we really believe
I think a lot of people have deathbed
conversions I think that's like a
standard meaning a deathbed conversion I
remember
I told the story before but uh Roger
Ebert when he died
you know he lost part of his jaw and but
he was reported to sit up in his bed and
and he just looked Blissful and said
it's all an elaborate hoax is what he
said meaning reality yeah and he said it
the the difference between paranoia and
Enlightenment is so fine sometimes sure
all a hoax sounds like paranoia no but I
like it it's it's beautiful the joyful
it's all a hoax meaning
it was all a dance or it was all a song
or it was all a dream or it was all a
play I was also thinking about
this morning and this pertains to what
you were saying so I'm gonna put it back
to you but I've always been attracted to
this joke that Daniel Tosh had about the
end of the world Whenever there was a
scare
before we really thought the world was
ending with covet and all these things
it was a trend that every six years or
so some church would say we've
interpreted the Bible the World's Gonna
and it would make the papers and I'd be
afraid every single time and Daniel Tosh
had a joke where he goes it would always
be after the fact he's like [__] we
didn't die like I was disappointed and
then he goes I don't want to die he goes
don't get me wrong I don't want to die I
want all of us to die and I this morning
for the first time I've always just been
so incalculably and inexplicably drawn
to that joke like I don't understand it
yeah and I was like that's because
that's I think that's Enlightenment a
personal death or a personal salvation
isn't salvation it's it's not real it's
all of us we all have to do it we all go
together and we all wake up and we all
go home whatever language you want to
use
and that I think that's what he said I
think he stumbled into something I'm
gonna say accidentally because most of
the time when I Stumble onto something
profound it was an accident I didn't I
didn't reverse engineer it I think he's
saying something profound there that
relates to this I think he is too
there's actually a wonderful book called
the idea of decline in Western history
by a guy named Arthur Hermann it's a
great book and it goes over how this
idea repeats itself and
we can't really Escape it and it is it
isn't like what idea what idea decline
the end of the world uh existential
threat like we always think it's
happening
always throughout history there's always
been something that threatened us all
that you know but not not Stakes high
enough because I think that people are
so amazing when it's actually happening
we do change we do pivot we do make
adjustments but when when it's just it's
just that there's always been the fear
of
whether it's the Bible or something else
that we're on our way out and that's
blood in the water that that's to me
spirituality at least where I'm at now
is is what we're saying it's going
through the darkness holding the hand
metaphorically of something hopeful but
it's not going around it it's not
everything happens for a reason it's not
God isn't going to give you something
you can't handle I always used to say
that but I was like you won't be able to
handle whatever kills you handle but
we're using it in the Physical Realm
we're saying God won't give you
something you can't handle yeah I
believe that spiritually this is a great
Jim Finley quote he goes I believe in a
God that protects me from nothing but
sustains me in everything that's what
that means God won't give you anything
you can't handle spiritually speaking
but physically speaking every single
person in the history of time has been
given something they couldn't handle
their heart their heart stopped beating
yeah what do we do with that we can't do
anything with it you have to say blood
in the water you have to claim blood in
the water and that has been a big part
of my spirituality is is owning the
darkness not just rejecting it or
looking the other way no and find some
beauty in it it can be beautiful too you
know like and it doesn't mean we have to
be rooting for
some tragedy I you know I like I I like
the idea of stuff being nice and people
being but also like okay when it happens
it can also like can I find can I find
something beautiful in it yeah yeah
that's right that's right and can this I
would say can this external thing push
me closer to an inner reality that was
always there that's Roger Ebert going
it's all a hoax he's included in that
hoax I would bet my my bottom dollar
that in that Revelation he's going what
you call Roger Ebert is part of the hoax
yeah you know I didn't I didn't
experience uh September 11th I was in I
was in rehab and um
very early in the morning
we saw there was there's one one TV and
we're we're out in the middle of nowhere
in Oklahoma and the TV showed a plane
crash into a building and then very
quickly they turned the TV off and so
today we're gonna spend the day outside
and we're not using the like it wasn't
um you know a plane had crashed into a
building before I I forget when that was
but it seemed like it was Empire State
Building yeah yeah it was a small family
right
um and then there were like a few days
go by where there they did they didn't
let any kind of conspiratorial like
you're not to use the phone it just
became more actively outside in the
middle of nowhere with no connection to
the outside when I finally got out of
rehab and I went to uh the airport and
there was a dude with a machine gun at
the airport I was completely bewildered
I was perplexed I didn't understand this
and then people were like well it's
because you know 911 and I was like oh
yeah I know I know that happened now but
people experienced something that I just
didn't experience and
I think it's awful that that happened
but because I didn't experience it I
can't get to the emotional level that
other people have this is this is the
younger people on our set by the way
yeah right 911 and we know this is going
to happen because this is what happens
we make Steve Martin as a joke where he
goes you make jokes as a young comedian
about cancer then your friends start
dying and you stop making jokes about
cancer these kids don't know 911 in the
same way we don't know the Great
Depression we don't know World War II we
don't know all these things right that's
one of the things but you were
it's almost like a second life like a
bubble was around around you guys and
you didn't receive the meal the trauma
the whatever it is because
for my friends in New York they went
through a war basically they went
through something visceral and and and
and and it changed them
um and then and then it seems to have
had this major Prof and I'm not saying
I'm aloof to what happened I know I know
what happened and I and I yeah of course
and emotions is different it touches me
it just I didn't experience it happening
so it's like somebody explaining a car
accident to you who was in the car
accident we're not we just I can't
experience the car accident that you had
right right it becomes a story yeah you
missed out on but we're sort of back to
what we were talking about it's like
these agreed upon realities and I'm not
denying those realities but like
narratives are spun stories are told
like your life is a story and that's and
that's again I see why you thought of
that Roger Ebert is like I was a story
yeah I was an agreed upon and you and I
didn't know Roger Eber to really know
what he's talking about it it's but I
like what he's talking about I like what
he's talking about too and having
that death before you die
that so that that that spaciousness that
like this is a hoax people don't have to
be like me it's not about eliminating
all suffering or as you were saying all
violence it's not Jesus said uh was
quoted to have said the the poor will
always be among you but I'm only here
for a limited time is basically what
he's saying he's like you should talk to
me while I'm here because you can't you
won't solve this right and there's you
could say that's defeatist and I'm I'm
all for fixing problems and helping and
all that I've been helped and that's
good but there's something about going
like I don't know if the game is to
finally tune the Earth like a German
watch I don't think that happens in a
world of Duality that doesn't mean we
can't uh improve but in a world where if
I'm sitting in this chair you're not
sitting in this chair right you can't be
sitting in this chair well I know we're
okay with that but like that's the
beginning of all of it is I'm in this
chair and you're not in this right here
I'm breathing this air you're not
breathing this air I have this coffee
you don't have this coffee that's what
Duality is yeah please homelessness is
an interesting one you said you play
these these moral games you you
moral questions yeah is it immoral to be
homeless
I there's the guilt of the society
that's not housing everybody but I I'm
with you I've played this before
if somebody says I don't want to live in
the way that you're living now look if
you come to my house and you say I want
to pitch a tent in your backyard and
have a bonfire I'm gonna say no and I'm
gonna take you off my property
that's just what I'm gonna do because I
don't want the bonfire in my backyard or
a stranger back there to be honest with
you yeah but I find nothing immoral
about somebody going I don't want to
play the game that you're playing that
this Society with cars and money and
credit cards I'm going to go wander
around to me there's nothing immoral
about that but then Society you know you
go to Los Angeles and it's like no
there's you know I think a couple of
years ago there was like cholera there
was an outbreak of Cholera because of
homeless encampments and like and I go
like I understand but is it just that
you want what you want versus they want
what they want and who's morally correct
and right private property
I'm okay with having my house that
nobody's allowed to come to and mess
with right but what about public
property everybody owns that and so is
it immoral for somebody to sleep there I
I don't know but yeah the the need to
solve it
I understand if you have a bunch of
people going like please give me a house
and then I think Los Angeles raised a
billion dollars to give them houses and
didn't turn out any houses which is that
true I think something like that maybe
it was 600 million
um
people want houses and want to play the
game I believe in opportunities but
again morally it becomes very weird
these things that we're solving because
they're wrong or right when I don't know
that they're wrong or right right well
you know it's interesting this
conversation this whole topic is
interesting I remember watching a
documentary where they they did what I
always wanted to do as a child which was
take a unhoused person and give them a
house and give and do the thing yeah I
guess you could say I have a savior
complex but I do like I I I like that
idea I'm like yeah yeah and look this is
just one case but that person
hated it that's what I'm saying that
that's exactly
oh it is the trouble is and you would
concede this that that's a convenient
um that's convenient data for people who
don't who would like to continue to step
over homeless people you know what I
mean I I listen I don't I take no
pleasure in stepping over homeless
people right I I'm simply saying
are we right in considering it to be
wrong right anymore if it's if it's not
if it's if it's fine to be homeless then
there's nothing to solve
yeah you know it's we're back at that
issue people don't have to be like me so
to to step at uh more comfortably for me
not that I'm worried about saying the
wrong thing maybe I am a little bit but
when I'm talking to my mother and I want
her to be a certain way and she keeps
touching the edges of my Operation game
and she keeps buzzing my nose yeah it's
because
I'm torturing myself
with thinking this shouldn't be I
haven't made friends with reality I
haven't forgiven reality and so Byron
Katie in the work did we ever talk about
Byron Katie yeah yeah yeah we did I'm a
fan of hers I love her so much I would
say um my mom needs to understand me she
would say is that true and that's what
you're doing yeah um it's it's wrong
that this let's just take one person
it's wrong that this person is sleeping
in the park is that true this person
doesn't want to be sleeping in the park
is that true
it just what it does is and what people
don't like about it is it removes all
all certainty and we love our certainty
and we'll actually rather suffer than
than be free in a lot of would rather
suffer and be certain than be free and
uncertain I think it is yeah well I
can't even absolutely figure out what is
certain for myself yeah that's right let
alone know what is certain for anybody
else but this touches me because meaning
I like that softness in your in your
heart because
and I'm not putting down my dad I just I
see my dad wanting people in my family
to be like him
and I remember saying to him I was like
kind of what we're saying I'm like that
that what you do which is when
and real estate wins and business wins
and you look like a success and you are
a success
that makes you happy we could we could
pause there we could unpack that yeah
but it's not fair to assume that that
would make this person happy and he
wouldn't concede that and that's okay I
can look big man beat I can forgive that
but I can I can not only forgive it I
can understand it but what is so
attractive to me especially
uh someone who's done so much work to be
strong to also go like I don't know what
I'm doing on a daily basis
I have to call it into question I have
to take an inventory of it is this
working is do I do I still want to do
the podcast is stand up right for me act
was that right like am I happy like like
I have moments like I said I feel
everything every day but I can't go
around and say to people you should
become a famous comedian you should
start a podcast you should like
I'm just doing an experiment every day
you know the biggest
um in my adult life you know I kind of
struggled with sobriety and my weight as
a kid and then I started and then I got
sober and that was a battle that I I I I
don't think it's I don't think it's a
win lose but I I'm not actively losing
that battle today yeah right I've got
the momentum and then I started working
on weight 20 years ago and this whole
time I'm figuring out I'm trying to
figure out or touch what is more correct
for me and all it is is a Harmony where
I feel that I'm in
maybe a slip stream you know you could
have a big pool of water and there could
be currents that are going at different
directions and one's taking you into the
rocks and one's taking you towards
wherever you're trying to get to and and
when I get into that lane I feel it one
of the things that I wanted so badly
with my kids was to not put restrictions
on food and alcohol and drugs because
there were nothing but restrictions for
me growing up and I felt that
I I don't think that's
um the totality of the issues that I
developed but I feel like it was a
partial contributor yeah and Ethan do
you want what's in my hand right you
know what I mean like yeah kind of right
it's it's it's part you can't have this
exactly I've got it and you can't have
you can't have it and then I had a kid
uh who at four got type 1 diabetes which
is juvenile diabetes it's immediately
insulin dependent
um you know and and suddenly I found
myself
in a position with my child saying this
is how it must be you must uh we must
count your carbohydrates we must give
you a shot for every one of them and
and it was a struggle because I I set up
these boundaries on her that for the
longest time remained very rigid
and then this [__] chick goes away to
boarding school and her her blood sugar
levels are all over the place and it
drove me truly insane because we would
get notifications on our phones
um and I actually had this conversation
with Byron Katie and and she asked me is
that true I said I just need my daughter
to have uh Pro I need her to be
responsible for her blood sugar and she
said is that true and I had to think
about that for a while and uh I it it's
not true yeah um and the minute I was
able to go
I've done the job I could do
and she's not a little kid anymore she's
she's now this this person's now 18
years old
and she's gonna have to figure out what
she wants out of life at some point all
that me stressing out about it does
is [__] up my life yeah yep and it
doesn't it doesn't take away any of my
love for her or Compassion or empathy
for her to really try and go I'm going
to give her a little space with this you
know what I mean yeah Katie is as
Fierce as reality yeah and that's what
makes her so appealing and that's also
what makes her so terrifying to people
because I've seen her do that sort of
thing with like
um like somebody dying and it's like I
can't live without them and it's like is
that true and it's like really really
rough yeah some people to hear things
like it's not romantic it's not very
dignified it's post-apocalyptic it's
[__] nature dude it's nature that's
what I mean and she goes reality wins
but only every time
and she's like your resistance to what
is
is driving you insane yeah and like
she's such a high level that it's like
if somebody wants to leave her she's
like let me help you pack right like I'm
not
and that but here's the thing that's not
just a person that has their physical
needs met that goes back to that Jim
Finley quote a god you could substitute
a different word there in Inner Strength
a source that sustains me in everything
and protects me from nothing yeah but
you have to you have to own the blood in
the water sometimes your partner leaves
sometimes your daughter gets type 1
diabetes and it's like
where can we loosen the grip but even as
you say that like human beings we're
grip Maniacs oh no even as I say it I
feel myself I feel my own grip which
I've really given a lot of space to it's
it comes back into my mind it might I
can feel it it's a it's more skin you
know
um and and then I have to take deep
breaths and wash it away and go like
we're all better off if I leave this
alone yeah she's she's actually better
off if I leave her alone you know the
the perhaps story
I'll tell it so briefly because I've
told it probably a thousand times
guy's house burns down everybody goes
what's attract what a tragedy he goes
perhaps because in the rubble they find
a box and it's filled with gold and they
go what a Mitzvah how great and he goes
perhaps then the gangster that buried
the gold comes and kills his family you
know like you can keep doing it yeah you
wouldn't do it with that that's you
wouldn't say bro you you have to deal
with things that are ambiguous your
daughters but I think a diabetes what a
tragedy perhaps you're like is this did
you get everything you've ever valued
from adversity from some [__] thing
going away I just talked to the guy here
in Ojai the air Pizza is the best pizza
in the world is incredible it's better
than New York anyway he's like yeah I
was kneading the dough myself I hurt my
hand and then I had to buy this machine
and the Machine is helping me make it as
good as it is and it was like right and
I go that was this morning I go isn't
that just how life Works yet we resist
it we every turn we kick and scream and
say not this time this time we want
inhale and no exhale yeah is it possible
that overcoming mislead it's perhaps
because it's perhaps with can we see
something beautiful in the rubble of a
of a city that got bombed right you know
what I mean it's the same thing if we're
not and it did well that's our [__]
tragic loss because now we're just
pessimists and miserable right right
that's right we can't find something
beautiful at all times with reality with
what is right I think we're losing you
hear those stories of concentrate people
in concentration camps having really
religious experiences yeah and look I'm
not here to tell anybody how to deal
with anything horrible I'm saying there
are people that told wrote these things
down the stories of like the worst
possible situations I mean what that's
being sustained and I think that's what
Katie's talking about when she did my
podcast I was like what about the kids
in cages you say everybody's okay you go
I don't worry about anybody because I
know everybody's okay like what about
the kids being separated at the border
and they're engaged she goes I'll I'll
protest I'll I'll petition all this but
I'll also know they're okay and you're
like whoa this is this is someone who
really believes that the the
the metric for okayness
actually isn't your physical
surroundings right and that's the story
of Jesus too he's okay on the cross I'm
sorry to keep using Christian stuff but
that's the story it's like you can kill
my body he's okay by the way that
doesn't happen you got no Christianity
yeah that's that's so like that's
perhaps let's [__] perhaps the
crucifixion yeah that's right oh man
they killed our savior what a bummer
some guy goes perhaps then they kill
they kill him they definitely kill that
they kill him back in those days but he
but he was right yeah he was right it's
perhaps okay we're almost out of time I
could talk to you forever I've written
down so many things I wrote down naming
a fish Eckhart Tolle and the Power of
Now you'll just enjoy this he's like we
think things are tragedies
um I'm not talking about the big ones
let's keep it in the in the shallow end
here but he's like just life and death
blood in the water because you uh he
goes a goldfish dies and you go yeah
that's what happens
you make peace with that you go like
goldfish die right and he goes but what
if I name the Goldfish what if I print
out a little piece of paper with his
name and his parents name and the day
and the time he was born and what if I
like his house I give him a deed to his
little goldfish and he was like that's
Raj Ebert going it's all a hoax you've
never not been in the place called here
you've never not been in the place in
the time called now which means there is
no here there is no now time and space
is a story you and me separation is a
story and and when we're lucky if we get
to the place where we can go like like I
hear it in what you're saying don't
worry about other people it's all
it's all happening inside of you and and
the gift is that there's some control
it's not really weight loss and it's not
really muscles it's I think why people
are interested in your story is because
we know
that we can talk about all the surrender
and out the with the other hand we can
have all this Runner and with the other
hand we can go and I think I might be
creating my reality right what I mean it
was I was life was happening to me
and now I am life and that's all that's
all it was and and again
I
I would never try to convince somebody
that they also had to experience because
you were converted you had a conversion
there's spiral do you know spiral
Dynamics by any chance it's the colors
of where you are in your Consciousness
it's a simple way of understanding it
and purple is um tribal and
superstitious and it's very like the
world happens to me and red is I happen
to the world it's actually early on the
on the Spectrum meaning it's not the
only transformation we have but it's an
important one and Breaking Bad I always
say Breaking Bad is purple to Red
hip-hop is purple to Red even super is
purple to red and we love purple to Red
it's why origin stories are almost
always better than just like and then
the next bad guy they fought it's like
[__] who cares we love seeing the
disempowered life happens to me I'm
broken I can't change it nothing happens
and then you do the thing you tie your
shoes you take that one breath you go
for that one walk or whatever it is
that's actually what we like we just
happen to be living in this
three-dimensional Universe where like
certain mindsets manifest in certain
shapes you know what I'm saying that's
not to say that you can't be a heavy
person and be brilliant and enlightened
and alive and free but in this case the
shape that it took was was Fitness and I
see it with other people in other shapes
and other sizes other colors other other
things but it's all
we love the purple the red yeah I'm I
I'm very happy with it there there's
times where my wife is like get really
into business and I'm just don't have
any interest
when people go accumulate real wealth
I'm like yeah you know what
having enough money seems pretty good
you know what I mean like that yeah
can't we just right is that like why do
we have to like we're not hungry and my
knees don't hurt as much as they used to
that's if you really need any more than
this if you move the carrot onto a
longer stick man
you know what I mean Mark Zuckerberg is
somewhere going like but how do I get
back on top you know what I mean and
you're like buddy yeah those those years
I was I was barbecuing on the surfboard
I Ruled the World
[Laughter]
and that I mean [__] forget it all
right we didn't get to every I mean so
many things it's great it doesn't matter
meaning you the tell the health tips
you've given me they're just gonna come
out and you can listen to me on American
Glutton we talked about a lot of them
yeah I'm glad we had the conversation we
had I'm really just trying to compliment
you and say I could talk to you forever
I love you Pete you're a wonderful guy I
love you too man I really do and and
thank you for being a symbol in my
Consciousness
I'm gonna work out today I love it it's
the biggest compliment and and all I
hear in my own head just so you know is
you're not worthy of this yeah I'm not
worthy of this person right you know and
I'm I'm going like no I'm I can have
yeah claim it it's okay it's not it's
not gonna shrivel you up like the wrong
chalice no no no certainly not
um can you tell me this is the last
question
a time in your life you laughed really
really really hard it doesn't have to be
a great story I'm just wondering if your
belly hurts and you're crying you might
have been a kid somebody might have
fallen it's often somebody falling or
farting
um maybe with great friends maybe with
your wife it doesn't matter I'm just
looking for where that question takes
you no wrong answers the the the thing I
um immediately think about is how much
joy my wife and children get out of me
falling
yes which will then lead to me laughing
also so we uh we have a doc and we're on
a canal in Florida and my wife bought
paddle boards which we never used
because because you don't use the things
you buy and so one day me and the kids
decided to try them out in the pool
which is 20 feet from the dock and if we
can do them in the pool we can do them
in the canal and uh the kids are pro
paddle boarders but I of course really
struggle and I'm nearly killing myself
by falling off because it's in a pool
and my wife and kids laughed so hard
that at one point I was in the pool
getting close to Drowning because I was
laughing so hard at my at them laughing
at me yeah that I couldn't stay above
water and that's what I think you almost
died and that's one of those deaths
you'd be like I mean it was a it was
worth it you know what I mean yeah like
look none of us want to but every once
in a while I've been like that would
have been a pretty okay moment like it's
the question talk about an ethical
question do you want to die when you're
up or when you're down do you want to be
like so happy and like suddenly you die
or do you want to be like this [__]
sucks get me out of here I have one
other dying laughing and this is the
second hardest I've ever laughed me this
is
30 years ago in New York
um I have a buddy who loves plays so
whenever I'm in New York with him he's
always like we're going to see these
four plays and we go to see plays and
one of them was in a smaller theater no
no and it was you know like there's no
there's there's only two aisles on
either end the seats aren't split down
the middle like that's how small it is
two people on stage very very serious
and I'm high as a kite on heroin and
probably nodding off heroin Giggles hair
well it got it
an older gentleman in front of us
shot out of his chair
in the middle of the play and then
ripped a huge fart and then made his way
out of oh no theater oh no I we all
assumed he was going to take a [__] I
mean it was so loud the people on stage
for sure heard him and me and my friends
could not pull it together we laughed so
hard and this play was like about
relationships and mentally women leaving
men like it was somber and this turned
it into a comedy for us he he got a
direct order yes to [__] yes and then he
stood up yes he was like yes sir he
tried to give the body what it wanted so
that the body wouldn't embarrass him and
the body was still like we're past that
point [__] you you should have done this
before yeah Val and I were just laughing
I love that story so much has there ever
been a fart that was beautiful like if
you didn't know it was a fart it was
just like a haunting like a
[Laughter]
for sure
there's been one but if you didn't know
it was a fart you'd wipe away a tear and
be like yeah it hits a note that makes
you think of like tranquil birds in a
sunset so like anything anything that's
pitched can make you cry exactly exactly
that was one of the best I mean you gave
us to I'll never forget
a man shooting up then farting then
going that's pretty good did your friend
know you were on her own was he also on
heroin he was not on heroin
um I believe I got uh
um an intervention at the end of that
trip
um
he's like look plays are already pretty
sleepy you don't need to go in on heroin
yeah no my friends were all very much
against the uh the drugs and I had a
number of interventions and again to I
think
um Byron Katie's advice of like I was I
was okay
until I wasn't okay for myself and
decided I needed to change right you
needed that conversion yeah other people
saw it first yeah this was great man we
thank you so much thank you Pete it's
it's a rare guest that can do a zoom one
but I knew when we did the pod in in
Toronto I was like yeah Ethan it's a
compliment Ethan's Zoom interesting not
a lot of people I'm gonna do it over
Zoom yeah we pulled it off we definitely
pulled it off I think people listening
on audio will be surprised to find out
here that it's Zoom unbelievable you're
incredible thank you listen everybody
listen to American Glutton your podcast
yeah and the end here would you say keep
it crispy it's just how we wrap up
keep it crispy
very nice thanks man I'll talk to you
soon Pete okay Ethan thanks pal enjoy
your day
[Music]